Clean your clothes in the future by simply
dropping this electrostatic spherical washing
machine into your laundry basket.
And this new vibrating pill has a tiny motor
that begins vibrating 6 to 8 hours after being
consumed and it produces contractions in the
intestines that help relieve chronic constipation.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.... this is Mind Blow
A Dutch designer has created wearable technology
that turns your clothes into an MP3 player.
The 3-D printed fabrics that make up the BB
suit give the user Wi-Fi, GPS, and bluetooth
components.
And the idea is to provide wearable as opposed
to carryable technology but producing these
on even a small scale is difficult right now
especially due to questions regarding durability
and washing.
SCiO is a pocket molecular sensor that can
detect the chemical makeup of objects.
Use it to get nutritional facts about food,
analyze soil, authenticate medications, see
how ripe an avocado is through the skin or
know which watermelon is sweeter.
Spectrometer technology isn't new but shrinking
one down to the palm of your hand is and it
could allow us to build a database of matter.
Professor Scott White and his team have developed
self-healing and regenerating plastic.
In the past self-healing and regenerating
materials were only able to fix small damages,
but this new technology has the ability to
regenerate materials to fill in large cracks
and holes.
The future of this breakthrough has a range
of applications including a car bumper repairing
itself within minutes of an accident.
CleverPet is a Wi-Fi-connected feeding dish
that teaches and entertains your dog while
you're away.
Your dog learns how to play with the cleverpet
by hitting different buttons to receive treats
and as the dog learns the challenges get harder.
It's basically like video games for dogs.
The Hive Inn is a hotel concept from Hong
Kong where the rooms are built out of shipping
containers.
And that's now a thing that you know!
Mink is a 3D printer that prints makeup.
It allows users to choose any color from any
image online and turn it into a wide array
of makeup products from eye shadow to lip
gloss because most makeup products are created
from the same basic substrates.
This new technology could provide access to
any makeup at an affordable price since many
products and colors are not available in chain
stores.
The University of Engineering and Technology
in Peru has created a billboard that purifies
air as efficiently as 1,200 trees.
It creates 100,000 cubic meters of clean air
by filtering polluted air through a water
system and releasing clean air back out to
a radius of 5 blocks.
And it's in response to the pollution created
as a result of Peru's booming construction
industry.
The LIX is a pen that writes in 3D allowing
you to doodle in air.
It melts and cools colored plastic as you
write which creates the rigid freestanding
structures.
All you have to do is plug it in for power
to heat the material as it flows through the
pen.
And it could lead to a whole new way of crafting.
This is the world's smallest comic that was
microfabricated with an ion beam onto a human
hair.
Microsoft is developing a keyboard that eliminates
the need for a mouse.
The Type-Hover-Swipe has gesture control sensors
between its keys and allows you to swipe and
pinch mid air to navigate through web pages.
And even claims to have gaming functions including
an invisible steering wheel.
Solar Roadways is a concept for replacing
roads and parking lots with a modular solar
paving system to power the world around them.
The panels would be heated to keep roads clear
of ice and snow as well as smart to alert
drivers if something is in the road.
The roads would also be marked with LED lights
instead of painted markings and parking lots
would be able to reconfigure parking in an
instant.
A researcher at the MIT media lab has created
super shoes.
A pair of flexible soles can be placed into
any shoes making them smart.
They work in conjunction with your smart phone
and can act as a navigation device sending
vibrations in your feet telling you when and
where to turn.
The shoes learn your regular patterns as well
as likes and dislikes and can navigate you
through different routes for variety or lead
you to a great restaurant you might not know
about nearby.
Finally Technicolour Alaska is a time lapse
capturing the Northern Lights as seen from
Alaska..
I'm going to leave you with a camouflaged
robotic snake.
And as always thanks for watching!